We conclude the Divine Comedy today.
And to understand the Divine Comedy,
it's very important to put in the
context of the other great books, okay?
So,
um in human history, there have been
three great poets.
The first is Homer.
Uh Homer.
The second is Virgil.
The third
is Dante.
Um
Homer gave us the Iliad [clears throat]
and the Odyssey.
And
by doing so, he constructed the basis of
Greek civilization,
which then became basis of Western
civilization.
Which Virgil, he will take Iliad and
Odyssey and we imagine it as the Aeneid.
>> [snorts]
>> The Aeneid will give rise to the Roman
Empire
and the Catholic Church.
And even though the Roman Empire and
Catholic Church are two fundamental
pillars of Western civilization,
the Aeneid will lead to a thousand years
at over thousand years of the Dark Ages,
when Europe
stops being creative, okay? Dante will
end the Dark Ages with the Divine
Comedy.
And the Divine Comedy will become the
blueprint for the Renaissance,
the Protestant Reformation,
and the Scientific Revolution,
and modernity itself, okay? Basically,
Dante would the world that we live in
today.
So, the question then is
how this happen? How's that Homer would
create Greek-civilization,
then Virgil would then
um erode-civilization, only be restored
by Dante?
The difference is in how they perceive
the role of humans, or what does it mean
to be human in this world? So, for
Homer, what he taught us is that love
is the unifying force of the universe.
So, remember that Odysseus, he spends 20
years trying to return to his family,
Penelope and Telemachus.
And that imagination
is the unifying force of the universe.
Okay? And what matters is the
individual, the individual's connection
to the source, or the monad. And if the
individual is able to connect to the
source, then that lights the universe.
Okay?
But what Virgil will do, because he
serves empire, is he will cut us off
from the source.
Okay?
And say, "No, what matters is piety,
obedience to authority."
And be And by doing that, we cease to be
individuals, we cease to be imaginative,
civilization stops.
So, what Dante has to do is reconnect us
back to the source.
And if he does that,
okay? Then that will restore the
imagination
as the fundamental animating force of
the universe. We can now be creative,
and this will set a new path for
humanity.
All right? So, throughout human history,
there have been two competing
countervailing forces. The force of
empire that wants us to that wants us to
obey it and therefore
cut us off from the source and the force
of civilization, of democracy, of love
that wants us to connect back to the
source and thus animate the universe
with our imagination, okay? All right.
So, um The Divine Comedy in in
other words, it's fundamentally a
conflict between Virgil and Dante. So,
Dante must defeat Virgil in order to
restore our humanity. And previously,
we've looked at
Virgil's ideas and today I want to look
at Dante's ideas.
Okay?
So,
um
we've been through Inferno, we've been
through Purgatory, and now we are in
Paradise.
Okay? And so, I want to show you the
framework for
um Paradise.
Now,
you may think that once we're in
Paradise, we've come to to the journey's
end. But in fact, Paradise itself is
another journey that is actually more
arduous. And Beatrice will be our guide
through the stars after we reach God,
okay?
So, what we will do is ascend through
the nine spheres in order to meet God.
Why do we need God? Because God will let
us know who we truly, fundamentally are.
All right. Uh this is another depicti-
depiction of our journey through the
cosmos. We start off on the moon, okay?
And then we'll make our way to the
Mercury and then we are we will try to
reach the Imperium where God and his
angels are. This is the center of the
universe. It is the source. This is our
journey's end.
All right.
So, we first start off on the moon.
And Beatrice is now Dante's guide.
And you would think that these are two
lovers that have not seen each other in
decades. You would think that they'd
just be happy hugging each other or
maybe they'd have a lot of sex. But in
fact what happens is that they start to
engage in the deepest intellectual
discussion.
This is deep philosophy, okay? So heaven
is fundamentally about debate,
dialogue,
and philosophy.
So in other words, this is a really
important idea, is that we suffered in
our world in inferno and purgatory not
to cleanse ourselves of our sins.
We suffered not in order to redeem
ourselves and and to make ourselves
um ready for heaven. We suffered in
order to gain the knowledge we requisite
necessary for higher learning in heaven.
All right, that's that's the purpose of
heaven, to discover the truth of the
universe, but we must first undergo
inferno and purgatory to prepare our
minds
for the challenge, the intellectual
challenge of paradise. Okay. So
Beatrice and Dante are having a
conversation about the cosmos.
And what she says is
um be thankful that you're here. And
here we will start a journey into the
truth of the universe.
All right, and what Dante says is with
the most devotion I can summon, I thank
him, God, for who has brought me far
from the mortal world. But now tell me,
okay?
I'm here to learn about the universe,
and the first question I have is
what are the dark spots on this planet's
body that there below on Earth shall
have have made men tell the tale of
Cain? She smiled somewhat and then she
said, "The opinion mortals hold falls in
error when the senses key cannot unlock
the truth. You should not be struck by
the arrows of amazement once you
recognize that reason, even when
supported by senses, has short wings.
But tell me what you think of it
yourself. And I, what seems to us the
verse up here is caused, I think, by
matter dense and rare. And she, you
surely will see that your belief is
deeply sunken error if you listen
carefully as I rebutted. Okay, so what
what is he saying? So the first question
that Dante has for Beatrice is, we're on
the moon
and on the moon at night there are some
dark dark spots, okay?
And he asked her, how do you explain the
fact that there are some dark spots on
the moon?
And she says, okay, well, the first
thing you need to recognize is that you
cannot figure this out by observation
and reason alone. That will only lead
you to error.
The true power is your faith, your love,
your intuition, your imagination. That's
what will lead you to the truth. But
humans are stuck using their observation
and their reason, their science to
figure out what what this is. So you're
always going to fall into error, but
it's okay. It's okay to make an error.
First tell me what you think is the
reason, okay? And then Dante says, well,
I think what most people think, which is
that it's because of the
um
density and rarity of the moon.
What this means is that there are some
places in the moon which is hollow,
okay? If it's hollow, then then that
means that light can just pass through
it.
Right? For there to be illumination,
there has to be reflection.
So the light can not pass through these
hollow parts of the moon
and escape into space. And so other
words, the dark spots are just the most
hollow aspects of the moon. And every
other place it's just very dense.
Okay? Which means light can't pass
through as we reflect back.
And that's from observation for reason
the most logical explanation.
Now, if you're curious as to why there
are dark spots on the moon, what
scientists believe is that the moon is
not hollow, but there's certain
rocks and minerals created by lava
that
and so the reflective quality of these
minerals is very low. Okay? That's
That's the standard explanation we have,
but quite honestly,
it's only a guess, okay? We're not
completely sure. All right, so this is a
mystery and um what Beatrice is going to
do now is explain this can't be true.
And the way she explains it is very
interesting. She's going to explain to
She's going to explain it using
scientific methods, experiments,
observations to show you how this can't
be true, okay?
So, the first thing she points out is
that
if it is true that there's certain
aspects of the moon, certain parts of
the moon that is hollow,
then how do you explain a
lunar eclipse, a solar eclipse?
Right? When the moon covers the sun
completely and the sun goes dark.
Well, if in fact there are hollow
aspects to the moon, it should not be
completely black, right? There should
the light should be able to break
through this these hollow aspects. So,
that shows you that first of all,
density and rare does not make any
sense. This is wrong. Okay? That's part
one.
Part two is, okay,
now you've seen yourself that well,
there are the moon is uneven, okay? The
topography is uneven and that there are
mountains and crevices.
Okay? So, in other words,
um
the dark are just really deep cavities
in the moon.
And then she says,
let's do an experiment.
And I'll show you that no matter how
distant
uh the reflection is,
the whiteness is still the same, okay?
So,
So, what she's doing is she's using the
scientific method, scientific method to
ex- experiments to show you that your
belief is wrong. And this becomes a
basis
of the scientific method, okay?
All right, so let's read it together.
The eighth sphere offers many lights to
you and you can tell that they in
quality or in size are stars with
different visages. If rarity that's
alone causes then all the stars would
share one power distributed lesser,
greater, or equal force. But different
powers must be fruits of different
formal principles. When were you
correct, one
only would be left, the rest destroyed.
And more were rarity the cause of the
dim spot you question, then in part this
planet would lack matter through and
through or else as in a body lean and
fat can alternate, so would this planet
alternate the pages in its volume, okay?
So, she points out number one, that if
it is true that density and rarity is
what causes the dark spots on the moon,
then it should be the same for every
other celestial body, every other
planet, every other star. Density and
and rarity is what matters. And she's
saying that's not true.
Okay?
Uh she's also pointing out that
your argument about density and rarity
means that the moon is uneven, right?
There are some whole spots to the moon.
Okay?
To validate the first case, in the sun's
eclipse, the light would have to show
through just as when it crosses matter
that is slender. That is not so,
therefore we must consider the latter
case. If no that too, then your opinion
surely is confuted, okay? So, she's
using the example the solar eclipse to
show us that it's not it can't possibly
be true that there are hollow spots to
the moon, okay? There might be some
shallow cavities to the moon, but there
are no hollow empty spots to the moon,
okay? Then she says, "If rarity does not
run through through the moon, then there
must be a limit where thickness does not
allow the light to pass. From there the
rays of sun would be formed back just as
from glass that hides lead at its back,
a ray of colored light returns
reflected." Now you say that that where
a ray has been reflected from a section
farther back, that ray will show itself
to be more dim. Yet an experiment where
to try it can fool you from your cabal.
Cabal just means doubt, and the source
of your art course springs from
experiment. Taking three mirrors, place
a pair of them at equal distance from
you, set the third midway between those
two, but farther back. Then turning
toward them at your back half place a
light that kindles those three mirrors
and returns to you reflected by them
all. Although the image in the farthest
glass will be less the size, there you
will see that it must match the
brightness of the rest, okay? So, what
you're saying here is okay, so the moon
is not completely hollow, there might it
might be very deep, okay? So, for
example, the moon might be like this.
In which case, you think that logically
speaking
this would be bright, this would be
bright, but this would be dark.
Okay?
Right?
And she's saying that's not true. If you
actually do a science experiment
okay, you will discover that this is not
true. And the science experiment she
says is this. Have three mirrors, okay?
Um
one here
one here, one here.
Okay? Just have three mirrors.
And then take a light. This is the
light.
And then shine it
so that the mirrors reflect. What she's
saying is like
the furthest mirror might be small and
the two
mirrors here may be larger, okay? The
size might be different, but the
brightness is still the same.
Okay?
If you were to do this, you would
discover this is true. And she's saying,
"Okay, but what's interesting is that
you can also extend this experiment and
say, 'Let's go further, okay? Let's just
say let's keep on going.'"
All right? This it would still be true.
In fact, you can go into eternity.
Okay? Just go through eternity and it
would still be true. Infinity.
The light at the end of the universe
would still burn as brightly as the
original source.
Okay? That's what she's saying here.
Does that make sense, guys?
All right.
All right. So, what she's done is she's
so she's shown that through science,
through
reason,
um through imagination, she's shown us
that
the moon
has dark spots
not because it's rare and dense. So,
then why is that the case?
And so So, here she shall explain.
Now, just as a submatter of the snow
beneath the blows of the warm rays is
stripped of both its color, former
color, and its cold, so should mind left
be or of error. I will offer now to to
you a new form, light so living that it
trembles in your sight. Within the
heaven of the godly peace revolves a
body in whose light lies the being of
all things that it enfolds. The spirit
that follows were so much as shown to
very essences bestows that being to
stars distinct and yet contained in it.
The other spheres in ways diverse direct
the diverse powers they possess so that
these forces can bear fruit, attain
their aims. So these organs of the
universe proceed as you now see from
stage to stage receiving from above and
acting downward. Now do attend to how I
pass by way of reaching the truth you
want that then you may learn how to
cross the ford alone. The force and
motion of the Holy Spirit must be
inspired by the blessed movers just as a
smith imparts the hammers art, okay? And
so from the
deep mind that makes it wheel the sphere
that many lights adorn receives a stamp
of which it then becomes a seal. And as
a soul within your dust is shared by
different organs, each must suited to a
different potency, so does that mind
unfold and multiply its bounty through
the very heavens though that intellect
itself revolves upon its unity. With the
dear body that it quickens and with
which as light in you it too is bound,
each different power forms of a
compound. Because of the glad nature of
its source, the power mingled with
sphere shines forth as gladness through
the living people shines. From this and
not from the matter rare or dense derive
the differences from light to light.
This is the forming principle producing
conforming with worth that dark the
bright, okay? All right, so what what
does this mean? It means let's go back
to the experiment.
What it means is that the universe is
created in a way in that there's one
source, okay? The source. And the source
is emanating light.
Okay, and this is divine light.
And this divine light is the underlying
fundamental principle of the universe.
And if you you bright, it means the
source is glowing brightly in you.
Okay? And so, think of the universe as
your own body, where you have organs,
you have hands,
you have eyes, okay? [snorts]
But, what is animating your body, what
is unifying your body, is your mind,
your consciousness. Okay? That is the
source. The universe work works the same
way, right? I'm moving my arms, I'm
looking at you, my eyes are burning
bright because of my consciousness,
because of my mind.
And so, the universe is is connected in
the same way, and the light
glows throughout the universe, and our
responsibility is to receive the light.
And how do we receive the light? By
loving, okay? By opening our hearts to
love. And once we receive the light,
then we imagine, and imagination is what
allows us to grow brightly, okay? Love
and imagination is what allows us to
grow brightly.
All right?
Okay. So, is this clear, guys?
All right? So, what she's saying is, you
don't look at the world as
through the lens of physical principles.
That doesn't get you anywhere.
Understanding the universe fundamentally
is about faith. It's about
consciousness.
It's about love and imagination.
All right.
Okay. So, now that
um so, this goes on for a long time,
where Beatrice is is slowly trying to
explain to Dante
the fundamental principles
of the universe, okay?
And
um
we're going to skip ahead to the very
ending.
This Divine Comedy is something that you
cannot read in a week or a year. It's
something that you have to read your
entire life reading. So, So entire point
of this class is is just prepare the
groundwork for you to to introduce ideas
and principles that will anchor your own
reading of The Divine Comedy, okay? But
we come to the end and so they climb all
the way up the
heavens and now they are in the
Imperium.
And the Imperium is the seat of God
and it's surrounded by angels and light,
okay?
And what's going to happen, and this is
like really strange,
is that first of all, Beatrice will go
away, she'll become an angel again, and
then Bernard will be Dante's guide in
the Imperium.
What is Dante's role in Imperium?
Dante's role is to meet God.
Why does Dante want to meet God? Because
God wants to meet him. Why does God want
to meet him?
Because there's a fundamental problem
in the universe and the and the problem
is this,
no one knows what God is. God doesn't
know, the angels don't know, no one
knows. Only Dante can know what God is.
So Dante has embarked on this long
journey for the cosmos, for inferno, for
purgatory, for paradise in order to meet
God to figure out what God is.
And you're like, wait a minute here,
this makes no sense. God knows
everything.
No, God is perfect. God is everything
and therefore God cannot know itself.
You understand? If you are perfect, you
lack an imagination
because you know everything. Therefore,
there's no limit to your knowledge.
But imagination means breaking through
the boundaries of knowledge. So this is
a really strange situation in that
God created humanity to know itself.
There and then through the course of
time, God picked an individual and this
person is Dante to come to God, to let
God know what it is fundamentally, to
know itself, to complete itself. That's
the great secret of Divine Comedy, okay?
But for Dante to figure this out,
he will have to spend the rest of his
life using his imagination to try to
unpack, unravel what God is. Because
when we first see God, God's like this
an infinite beam of light. You're like,
what is this? Okay? He doesn't know. So,
he has to constantly imagine what God is
before he can finally come to the
answer.
All right? Okay. So, what's going to
happen is this.
Bernard, before introducing Dante to
God, he she he's going to pray to Mary,
the queen, okay, the virgin mother, for
inspiration
to guide
Dante.
Okay?
Um
and why is Dante the only person in the
world who can let God know what it is?
The answer is because Dante is a human.
And a human has two aspects, a soul
and a body.
A soul connects to the source,
okay, to the divine. But the body
connects to the material.
The body can sin, it can suffer. It
feels pain, it feels pleasure.
Therefore, there's a limit to it,
therefore it has an imagination. Because
there are so many things to it that it's
not known. So, when you as a human, when
you're able to combine the best aspects
of who you are, both the body and the
soul, that gives you an imagination that
is divine. That allows you to connect
back to the source, but also allows you
to expand the universe, okay? That's why
only Dante can tell what God what it is.
Not the angels, not Bernard, not not
Mary, okay? Only Dante.
All right. So, let's read.
So, this is the final canto, okay? The
end of the Divine Comedy. We've come to
the end. This is heaven. This is the
Imperium. This is God. And so, Bernard
says to Mary, "Virgin mother, daughter
of your son, more humble and sublime
than any creature, fixed goal decreed
from all eternity, you are the one who
gave to human nature so much nobility
that its creator not disdain his being
made its creature. That love whose warm
allowed this flower to bloom within the
everlasting peace was love rekindled in
your womb. For us above, you are the
noonday touch of charity and there below
on earth among the mortals, you're a
living spring of hope. Lady, you are so
high, you can so intercede that he who
would have grace but does not seek your
aid may so long to fly but has no
wings." Okay, so what Bernard is saying
is that Dante is on a special mission to
help God know itself.
So, let us remember and celebrate a
woman, a mortal woman,
who was also
um who also
who also expanded the possibilities of
humanity, okay? Because she was so
noble, she was so generous, she was so
loving that in her womb she was able to
contain God itself. So, God was able to
come into our world through the portal
that is Mary, okay? And as such, God is
able to
reunify with us and to spread himself to
us, okay?
All right. So, basically, Dante is
completing another mission that Mary
first started.
"Your loving kindness does not only
answer the one who asks, but is often
ready answer freely long before the
asking. Your compassion is in you is
pity, in you is generosity, in you is
every goodness found in any creature.
This man, whom from the deepest hollow
in the universe up to this height has
seen the lives of spirits one by one,
now pleads with you through grace to
grant him so much virtue that he may
lift his vision higher still, may lift
it toward the ultimate salvation.
Okay, this is really important to
understand.
Higher vision still is the imagination.
So, if Dante is to see God, if God Dante
is to know God, he can't do it with his
eyes. The vision doesn't matter.
Everyone has eyes. The higher vision is
the imagination, okay? But how do you
activate the imagination? Through
virtue, through love.
Okay? It is the love that will give you
the imagination to see the ultimate
salvation, which is God. And this is how
the universe works, okay? Dante has been
selected because of his imagination and
because of his virtue. What is his
virtue? His virtue is his eternal love
for Beatrice.
Okay? What is his imagination? His
poetry.
That is what will enable him to know God
and allow God to know itself.
And I, who never burned for my own
vision more than I burned from for his,
do offer you all my prayers and pray
that they may not
I can't see God. I don't know God. I'm
next to God. I live with God.
I'm part of God, but I don't I can't see
God. Only Dante can see God.
Okay?
Fall short that with your prayers you
may disperse all the clouds of his
mortality so the highest joy be his to
see. This too, oh queen, you can do do
what you would. I ask of you that after
such a vision, he still preserve the
perseverance, okay?
Yes, so Dante will see God.
But God is so powerful,
the vision will be so powerful that it
will blow his mind, okay? It will
literally blow his mind. So,
Dante must use his virtue, his love,
his verse soul to maintain the shadow of
this image, okay? To remember
a
shocking memory, okay?
That is the goal here.
"May your protection curb his mortal
passions." See Beatrice, how many saints
with her, they join my prayers, they
clasp their hands to you, okay? His
mortal passions is basically fear and
the ego.
To truly understand God, you must
abandon your mortal passions, your ego
and your fear.
You must be completely vir- virtuous,
you must be complete imagination, you
must be complete love.
"The eyes that are revered and loved by
God now fix upon the supplicant showed
us how welcome such devotions are to
her. Then her eyes turned to the eternal
light. There do not think that any
creature's eyes can find its way as
clearly as her sight." "And now I, who
now was nearing him, who is the end of
all desires as I ought, lift my longing
to its ardent limit." Beatrice
signaling, he smiled to me to turn my
eyes on high, but I already was doing
what he wanted me to do, because my
sight becoming pure was able to
penetrate the ray of light more deeply.
God is pure light, okay? That that light
is the blind which in itself is true.
From that point on, what I could see was
greater than speech can show. At such a
sight, it failed and memory failed when
faced with such excess. As one who sees
within a dream and later the passion
that had been imprinted stays, but
nothing of the rest returns to mind.
Okay, so he's now looking at God and his
mind is blown away. His mind, his brain
cannot comprehend what he's seeing,
okay? It's like a dream where you dream
something and you can't you can't
remember anything but the impression,
the feeling of that dream, okay? All he
remembers is being awestruck by it.
"Such am I, for my vision almost fades
completely, yet it still distills within
my heart the sweetness that was born of
it. So it's a snow beneath the sun
unsealed and so on the light leaves
beneath the wind the articles the civil
ones wrote were lost.
O highest light, you raise so far above
the minds of mortals to my memory give
back something of your epiphany. Okay,
so it's almost like the more metaphor is
I'm just a flake of snow and now I'm
before the sun. So I just
burst, okay? There's nothing left. Okay?
There is a light, okay? So what
So now what's happening is this. He's
saying 20 years ago
I had this vision. 20 years later I'm
alone at home and I'm I've been trying
for the past 20 years to remember what I
saw, to use my imagination to
reconstruct what I saw, okay? So we're
now we're now move forward in time.
We're we're we're now 20 years ahead.
Okay? We're 20 years ahead and now he's
in his room somewhere in Italy trying to
remember what he saw.
And make my tongue so powerful that I
may leave to people of the future one
gleam of glory that is yours for by
returning somewhat to my memory and
echoing a while within these lines your
victory will be more understood. So
Dante's mission is not just to
understand God, to help God know itself.
Dante's mission is actually to report to
us what he saw. Okay?
To reveal to humanity the true nature of
God so that we we may know ourselves
and be better humans.
The living way that I endured was so
acute that I believe I should have gone
astray had my eyes turned away from it.
I can recall that I because of this was
bold in sustaining it until my vision
reached is goodness. O grace abounding
through which I presume to set my eyes
on the eternal light so long I spent all
my sight on it. And so profoundly I saw
in gather and bound by love into one
single volume what in the universe seems
separate scattered substance accents and
dispositions as it can join in such a
way that what I tell is only
rudimentary. So when he saw God, he saw
the totality of the universe.
Everything was interconnected in some
way.
Okay? God is infinite, it's eternal,
it's everything, it's nothing.
I think I saw the universal shape which
take not
which that not takes. For speaking this
I feel joy that is more ample, that one
moment brings more forgetfulness to me
than 25 centuries have brought to the
endeavor that startled Neptune the Argo
shadow. So it's my mind completely
wrapped intent, steadfast, and
motionless gazing and it would grow ever
more enkindled as it watched. Whoever
sees that light is soon made such that
it would be impossible for him to set
that light aside for other sight.
Because that good, the object of the
will, is fully gathered in that light
outside that light what there is
is perfect is defective, okay?
So he's seeing the entirety of the
universe that's perfect, that's
immutable, that's eternal. All right?
What little I recall is to be told from
this point on in words more weak than
those of one whose infant tongue still
babes at the breast. So not only is he
trying to figure out what that thing
was, what God is, but he's also trying
to use words to describe that. And he
And he And he And he discovers that this
is really silly. Words can't possibly
describe what I just saw.
Okay? So he's frustrated.
And not because more than one simple
semblance was in living light at which I
gazed for it is always what it was
before, but through my sight which as I
gaze stronger, that so appearance even
as I altered seemingly changing in the
deep and bright essence of that exalted
light, three circles appear to me.
They're three different colors, but all
of them were the same dimension. Okay.
So, now he's figured it out. After 20
years of constantly meditation,
he's figured out what that thing was.
And he And he said that at the essence
of God are three circles. They're the
same, okay?
They're just three circles. Different
lights, but they're the same. And
obviously,
we know what this is now. It's the Holy
Trinity.
Right?
This is the essence of Christianity.
Christianity teaches us that God is the
Godhead.
Right? Three aspects. The Holy Spirit,
the Father, and the Son. Okay? So, I
looked into God and I saw the Holy
Trinity. That's makes sense.
Right?
One circle seemed reflected by the
second as rainbow is by rainbow, and the
third seemed far brief equally by those
two circles.
Okay? So, they're just reflecting each
other.
How
incomplete is speech and how weak when
set against my thought. And this to what
I saw is such to call it little is too
much. Eternal light, you need dwell
within yourself and only you know you.
Self-knowing, self-known, you love and
smile upon yourself. That circle which
began so appeared in you as light
reflected when my eyes have watched it
with attention for some time. Within
itself and colored like itself to me
seemed plain over effigy, so that my
sight was set on it completely.
Okay? There's a problem. Okay? He's seen
the Holy Trinity. It's three concentric
circles. That's fine, okay? And they're
all reflecting each other. There's a
fire inside them.
But there there's a problem with all
this.
He said that the the longer I look,
the more I concentrate, I discover
there's a problem in the Holy Trinity,
which is like where in the stupid thing?
There's an effigy. There's a human
likeness inside
the
Holy Trinity. That makes no sense.
Because God is beyond us.
Okay? That's why we must obey God
because God is a mystery.
It's because God is so distant from us.
Therefore, we must bow to it, be humble
before it. But what Dante is saying is
like, I looked into the soul of God and
we are inside it at its very heart. This
makes absolutely no sense.
All right?
As the geometry, I sorry, as the
geometer intently seeks to square the
circle, but he cannot reach through
thought unthought the principle he
needs, so I search a strange sight. I
wish to see the way in which our human
effigy suit the circle and found place
in it. He can't figure it out. This is
the greatest paradox in the universe.
Why are we inside God?
Why?
My own wings are far too weak for that,
but then my mind was struck by light
that flashed and with this light
received what I had asked. Here force
failed my high fantasy, but my desire my
will were moved already like a wheel
revolving uniformly by the love that
moves the sun and the other stars.
Okay, I can't figure it out.
But I want to figure it out.
And I feel as though I'm changed
by this process
of trying to figure this out.
Okay?
So, that's it. The Divine Comedy.
This is how it ends.
It doesn't end with the answer. It ends
with a question. Why are we inside God?
What's the meaning of all this?
Okay? And this is all very confusing
because this is how it ends and he
doesn't give us the answer. And so the
thing to understand about the Divine
Comedy is that it's not meant to be the
Bible. It's meant to inspire you to
to [snorts]
embark on your own journey into the
depths of the universe.
Okay?
And so you need to reread the Divine
Comedy many many times throughout your
life.
And with each reading, you'll have a
deeper understanding of the Divine
Comedy.
And
with each reading,
it will change how you live. It will
change how you see see yourself.
All right? Okay. So,
what is the secret here? What's the
answer?
What is God?
Okay. Well, the first thing is,
what does this remind us of? Have we
seen this before?
Three circles with a human inside of it.
Actually, we have.
Okay, we've seen this before
in this class.
Okay, so I'll I'll show you where it is.
Okay.
Sorry, it's going to it's going to take
some time to get to it.
But here it is. This is God.
All right?
Because Beatrice was showing us through
the through the experiment. And she
says,
"Take three mirrors, okay? And then
shine a mirror
shine a candle
so that the candle is reflected in three
mirrors."
And she tells us, "Hold that candle.
Okay? You're holding the candle.
And as a result,
not only is the candle reflected inside
the mirrors, but you yourself is
reflected in the mirrors, as well.
To all of eternity.
What is this?
It's a godhead
that Donny saw in his vision. [music]
All right?
So, what's happening is that Donny is
reminding us of this experiment.
And he's also reminding us that if you
continue to extend this experiment, it
extends into infinity. All right?
And so, this is what God is.
God is the candle
that burns in us.
We all have a candle inside of us, and
it burns.
And it reminds And because it is the
memory of God. It is God in us.
Now, the question then is, okay, what is
this candle thing called? What is it
that burns in us? And the more good we
do, the
the
more intense it burns.
And what is this candle that that's able
to reflect throughout the universe?
That's mirrored in each other.
Well, it's love.
So, this is the great secret of the
universe. God is love. You You want to
know what God is?
Love someone.
And you will feel God. Because it's a
candle burning inside of you.
And how do you know you're truly in
love? Because your imagination will
expand. You will see the world in a new
way. You will see the world through the
mind of God.
You will You will reunite with God.
Okay? And that's the great secret of the
universe. And once you understand this,
the way you see the world will be
completely different. The way you see
read Dante will be completely different.
Okay? So, what we're going to do now is
we're going to take this knowledge that
that we have, that God is love, that God
is the light, the spark in us that burns
and never extinguishes inside of us.
And we're going to reread the ending,
and you'll see how now we have the
higher vision.
Now the universe has been revealed to
us.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
Okay, the ending is this.
Here force failed my high fantasy, but
my desire and will were moved already
like a wheel without a uniformly by the
love that moves the sun and the other
stars.
Okay?
So, what's happening is
I figured out what God is.
And I realized it's our reason that
matters. Okay? It's desire and will. I
feel my whole soul moving by the love
that moves the sun and the other stars.
Okay? He understands.
God is love, and love is the fundamental
fundamental
power that unifies the entire universe.
Okay?
So, you see how you see what what what
did I call many years? On your first
reading, you can't figure it out. But
the more you read, the more it reveals
itself to you, and the more you read,
the secrets start to uncover themselves.
Okay?
In the first reading, we were left with
a question.
What did Dante see? Now that we
understand what Dante
saw, we can see the universe in the same
way that he saw it as well. So, Divine
Comedy is first and foremost a portal
into the mind of God.
Okay, and that's what a great book is.
All right? Okay.
So,
um enjoy Divine Comedy. It is the
greatest work of literature in the
world, and it will change who you are
forever.